welcome to this video playing sharp oh
true yeah what is still possible in
terms of offbeat stuff maybe b6 this is
borderline really border line playable
ok this is ok 93's am a bit meek that is
really a playable position for black ok
d 3 so he's playing it in a very
restrained fashion not very ambitiously
so that seems like a decent version of
the french defence i would see actually
cover ie5 he doesn't I think okay so
mm-hmm
so let's get the pawn bishop d6s not be
five so I have to prepare that you might
have Bishop g3 and f4 wow that is that's
like coming up with the bed legs he
wants to sacrifice on e6 wow that sure
normal measures loose so you have to be
have to yeah bring out the big guns but
is it working is it working Bishop 66
mm-hmm I had looks dangerous and this
look dangerous
okay let's start with them
you
if I castle he has 96 yeah he really has
that move oh that cadet gets dangerous
haha wow I didn't expect that it really
looked like complete complete rubbish
blundering the center porn and stuff oh
wait I can take on g4 actually and I can
take them it's night f2 that's not if to
check okay that's that's much easier so
taking on c3 is a piece right
yeah that the hewitt resign as an
excellent compensation all of the Sun I
mean it's hard to believe yeah because
like d 3 a 3 and so on it looks like how
slow can you play it but it was
surprisingly dangerous really i mean not
dangerous it was probably good for white
amazing so maybe queen bee 8 isn't
really that great yeah can the the
computer is just doing it differently a
6 Bishop e7 and g5 yeah the clear
advantage for black yeah probably the e5
pawn is not it's not supported at all
really standard data is really what's
dangerous really dangerous probably
bishop these successes maybe to lock
lecture i cannot pronounce that word too
much over yeah bit bit too much so yeah
and now he has to smash on his sexy 96
but should be six one of those it looks
dangerous really dangerous
stockfish is on equal check check equal
if it says what it says I report and
upon down here right for vague
compensation with the bishop pair wow
great yeah he had a good position he had
a good position and still that the
engine says I should take I don't
understand the move at all I thought
check this is just bad I've could who
conform okay and okay this lose a soul
but what else there are some other moves
we need to it's an interesting move on
this is also interesting wyd win c5 back
what has a good position here it's just
like that just like that i was quite
lucky that he that he stumbled into that
one chand i'm winning a piece on a son
wow ok yeah about the opening the the
problem with be six is not 93 but it's
this this is this is the problem Lex
counter plays very limited in this case
and it is a situation where why does
having a central dominance and very
difficult for black to get come to play
hello I can look at this a little bit
more in the review video after this week
okay well thanks for watching